hi I'm Ryan Sumner I'm a chief network
architect with IBM cloud and today I'm
gonna give you the basics of a DDoS
attack a DDoS attack is an attempt by an
attacker to create so much traffic or
congestion to a target application or an
Internet application that it impedes the
traffic flow for normal visitors so what
the normal visitors might see or the
owner of the application might see as a
result of a DDoS attack being impeded
upon them is they might see a drastic
reduction in speed they might see a
complete outage or they'll see it's just
some unexplained consequences that they
don't normally see within their
day-to-day operations so to demonstrate
this a bit more I'll show to you how
normal traffic flows from users on the
Internet to the target server using its
internet connection here so we'll have
normal Internet users here we'll have
the clean traffic that comes through the
internet and traverses to through the
connection from the Internet to the
target server so this traffic flows just
perfectly fine with no slowdown or
there's no there's no constriction on
that traffic flow so now if we have so
how does an attacker create so much
traffic that it causes an inability for
this clean traffic to flow from the
Internet to the target server through
its connection so does the attacker just
have that many friends usually not and
he's not going to pick up the phone and
say jump on your computer now let's all
attack this target server he's done his
homework and he has access to a
collection or a network of attacked or
or hacked or compromised computers
across the internet sometimes these
might be IOT devices they might be
people's computers they might be other
servers on the internet but all of these
attacked or compromised computers are at
the control of the
tacker and we call that network a botnet
the reason it's called a botnet is
because now the attacker can remotely
control this network of hacked computers
almost like they're robots and it can
the attacker can tell that botnet what
to do and exactly for how long and
exactly when he wants to do it so the
attacker when they are ready to create
the to start the attack will call on all
of these hacked computers or robots
within the botnet and start to generate
traffic from all of these systems over
the Internet now what ends up happening
is we create congestion through this
pipe that's coming from the Internet to
the target server so as this congestion
is is occurring and they and and this
never stops right they've created so
much congestion across it and the amount
of time that the botnet is being
executed continues to exceed continues
to exceed and these Internet users are
continuing to attempt to come in however
the pipe is so congested that they can
no longer enter the roadway so this is
the basics of a DDoS attack so if your
application is slow you're experiencing
downtime or just other odd behavior you
might be under a DDoS check below for
more information leave us some comments
ask some questions and if you like this
content please subscribe and like